you
hi my name is Anand and I'll be talking
about resource center we are exploring
ways to create intelligent and efficient
cloud platforms
to do this we want to leverage machine
learning into the cloud platform
resource management there are several
research challenges like how can we make
this machine learning integration
generic enough so the idea is to put
resource central right into the center
of Azure as you see here various
resource management services in the
cloud platform can talk to resource
central and get predictions about the
future behaviors so resource central is
a general platform for collecting
telemetry learning about the prior
behaviors of VMs and servers and when
requested it can produce predictions of
the future behavior we have some
highlights here we had a paper in a CSP
17 about this the resource central
service is currently in production in
Azure computer brick here we can see the
architecture of resource central there
are two main parts of it there is
offline processing where you collect
telemetry you create machine learning
generated models and there is an online
serving platform which allows the
resource managers to make queries to
resource central and serve predictions
as you can see with resource central we
can predict with a high quality various
matrix of workloads that is a strong
reason to integrate machine learning in
resource management in plat fans here we
have some future machine learning
challenges that we are trying to address
for example online learning and doing
this at scale now we have a small demo
here which shows the VM scheduling and
in Azure using resource central and
without using resource center say as you
can see here without using resource
central
there will be a high probability of
rejections of workloads because of the
fixed capacity of the wheels with
resource central you get informed
knowledge about what is the kind of
workload and the nature of that workload
with that information you can achieve
oversubscription with the same capacity
and without exhausting the resources
several number of times so in this
approach without resource central you
can see there are high number of
rejections
whereas with resource center and
rejections are low and also that we are
remaining within the capacity of the
soil thank you
you